so an ama in your hands and then six  Grammy nominations in the future  where were you when you found out about  the Grammy nominee and then my the CEO  Columbia called me like at five in the  morning and then like he just started  yelling pretty much and like you know I  was in I was in shock with a lot of  nominations you know and I'm just like a  scream Li thankful and happy to even be  considered you know if I don't have to  win one of these awards you know I'm  just happy to have them it's been such a  monumental year for you how do you go  into the holidays and just thinking  about everything that's happened to you  both personally and career-wise it's  been just very huge thinking about it oh  yeah all the time I guess I'm like in a  in a constant state of you know  realization and like just like life in  general how everything is happening for  me and just and then you know just  grateful overall  [Music]